and then when people say I want bobu you
just have to question them yeah that's
minging I've had two sips for some
reason in Hell sorry
Gea are youing joking you've just ruined
M I can't see you on there anyway you're
in C oh my God sorry Rob what the mate
I'm just this my first way you just got
it all over the sketches are youing
joking wait these are air memory wrong
with you I'm vegan
bro not only not only am I vegan I'm
Hindu by origin and you just sprayed me
with beef
juice oh my that's the Dr I can't go to
see my mom I can smell cow on
you I can smell Ma's beef juice on you I
know have you have you been trying M's
beef juice again I mean unless you've
got like liquid dog in
these I think we know what the winner is